sie ist gekommen um zu gehen um ihre
Partei hinter sich zu lassen
Bundespressekonferenz heute
morgen wir sind heute aus der Partei
ausgetreten weil es tatsächlich ja also
ich finde meine wenn man mich
ausschließen will es ist tatsächlich so
wir haben ein anderes Projekt das ist
halt so wenn die Oma Krebs hat dann weiß
man das geht zu Ende und dann wenn sie
tot ist s doch alle traurig und ein
bisschen ähnlich ist das ja auch es wird
natürlich dazu führen dass der dem dass
der Diskurs von zwei Seiten populistisch
polarisiert wird es ist halt wirklich
tragisch und das sage ich als Dramaturg
dass die Linkspartei sich so störrisch
ihr gegenüber verhalten hat und auch
immer störrischer Verhalten hat so wie
es derzeit läuft darf es nicht
weitergehen ein Parteiprogramm gibt's
noch nicht zunächst ist man ein Verein
das Bündnis SAR Wagenknecht fordert
wirtschaftliche Vernunft Gerechtigkeit
Frieden und
Freiheit gute Rahmenbedingungen für
einen innovativen Mittelstand soziale
Gerechtigkeit Frieden Diplomatie und
Verhandlungslösungen dieser
Konformitätsdruck war in der coronazeit
extrem es gibt so viele die mir
schreiben dass sie erleichtert sind dass
sie sich freuen ich werde auf der Straße
teilweise sehr sehr nett angesprochen
und ich glaube wir können hier etwas in
Bewegung setzen was wirklich unser Land
zum Guten verändert auf dem Land in
Brandenburg wohnt der Dramaturg und
Publizist Bern Stegemann lautstark hat
er die Linke in den letzten Jahren
kritisiert doch mit der neuen Partei da
hadert er eine neue Sara wnechtpartei
wird mit dem riesigen Problem zu tun
haben dass sie sehr sehr viele Menschen
anzieht die vorsichtig formuliert
vielleicht nicht unbedingt konstruktiv
mit Demokratie und konstruktiv mit den
Problemen in diesem Land umgehen wollen
ich glaube das ist auch der Grund warum
Wagen nicht so lange nach gedacht hat
und lange gezögert hat weil ihr das
natürlich sehr klar ist welche welche
Büchse der Pandora sie jetzt öffnen wird
wenn Sie diese Partei gründet 5 Jahre
ist es her da waren Bern Stegemann und
Sarah Wagenknecht Mitbegründer der
Sammelbewegung Aufstehen zu woke sei die
Linke auch die Flüchtlingspolitik wurde
kritisiert doch organisatorisch ging man
schnell unter 170 000 Unterstützer und
wir hatten Null Fähigkeit Null Kapazität
das irgendwie zu strukturieren zu
organisieren und dadurch haben sich eben
vielfach auch an vielen Stellen auch
irgendwelche Glücksritter da
eingeschlichen die haben die anderen
Leute so lange genervt bis sie davon
gelaufen sind das soll diesmal anders
laufen im Bundestag plante Sarah
Wagenknecht Wand an Wand zu dietm Barsch
ihre neue Bewegung mit dem führte sie
jahrelang die Linksfraktion nun werden
sie zu politischen Gegnern ich weiß ja
dass die neue Bewegung sogar Seminare
gemacht hat was können wir auf Aufstehen
lernen also es ist ja alles nicht im
Verborgenen geblieben also man darf ja
nicht so tun wie manche Medien dass es
alles überraschend ist und dass das in
einem Zimmerchen ausgedacht worden ist
das stimmt ja nicht das ist strategisch
vorbereitet Sarah Wagenknecht vor ein
paar Tagen auf dem Weg zu ihrer letzten
Abstimmung als Mitglied der LINKEN bei
denen begann sie als kommunistische
Außenseiterin machte dann eine
erstaunliche
Parteikarriere jetzt ist der
jahrzehntelange gemeinsame Weg zu Ende
es gab sicherlich viele einzelne
Ereignisse ich kann mich wirklich sehr
gut weil ich das neben mir an den
tortenwurf damals erinnern das war ganz
schlimm und furchtbar und natürlich es
gab einige in der Partei die alles daran
gesetzt haben dass sie nicht mehr dabei
ist 2016 warfen Aktivisten SAR
Wagenknecht eine Torte ins Gesicht zuvor
hatte sie gefordert kriminelle Ausländer
auszuweisen eine flüchtlingsobergrenze
einzuführen die Linke wurde ihr
zunehmend frem
EE fr
derzialenungerechtigkeit oben und unten
aus den Augen verloren so kritisierte
sie da geht es um Identitätspolitik um
eine bestimmte Sprache da geht es um
Antirassismus um radikalen Klimaschutz
und das mag man alles wichtig und
richtig finden aber es ist eben eine
Ausrichtung wo dann der Normalbürger die
alleinstehende Mutter die Verkäuferin
sagt ja und wo bleiben meine Probleme
ich komme mit meinem Einkommen nicht
über den Monat hil ist Politikberater
war Wahlkampfmanager bei den Grünen ihr
politischer Hauptgegner sie will links
konservativ im Grunde sein sie will
einerseits
die Retterin der Republik vor einem
vermeintlich linkswoken
Zeitgeist sein und andererseits aber
auch die Verteidigerin der Demokratie
vor der AFD und das ist doch schon im
Grunde sehr interessant weil sie damit
so so die klassische
linksrechtsdualität des
Parteienspektrums auflöst das machte
auch schon Sarah wagenknechts große
Friedensdemo Anfang des Jahres sie
forderte Friedensverhandlungen im
ukrainekrieg Unterstützung von ihrer
Partei bekam sie nicht sie haben
wirklich Angst vor uns sie haben Angst
vor einer neuen
Friedensbewegung Donnerstag in Halle in
einem Theater will Sarah Wagenknecht aus
ihrem Buch die selbstgerechten lesen der
Bestseller ist eine scharfe
Gesellschaftskritik Hall das Mitglied
des Deutschen Bundestages dr Sarah
Wagenknecht kurz zuvor wurde bekannt
dass Sarah Wagenknecht es jetzt macht
dass sie ihre eigene Partei gründen wird
der Saal ist voll der Politologe
Konstantin wurtmann sagt vor allem
konservativ und migrationskritisch
denkende Menschen werden Wagenknecht
wählen und die gibt's vor allem bei der
AFD aber auch unter den Nichtwählern das
große Problem ist dass momentan vor
allen Dingen AFD Wählerinnen und Wählern
erklärt wird sie seien zu dumm die
eigene prekäre Lebenssituation zu
begreifen und sie spricht ja auch genau
dieses Thema an und sagt man muss mit
Wählerinnen und Wählern der AFD anders
umgehen aber gleichzeitig biet sie
natürlich diesen Wählerinnen und Wählern
eine ja demokratische exit Strategie
weil eine Partei die Wagenknecht gründen
würde wäre auf jeden Fall eine
demokratische Partei der moralisierende
linksliberalismus ist längst in einen
neuen Autoritarismus gekippt der
totalitäre Züge trägt und die liberale
Demokratie durch eine extreme Verengung
des geduldeten meinungsspektrums
untergräbt nun geht's ums ganze um die
Zukunft wagenknechts und die der
deutschen Linken so Bern Stegemann wenn
diese Partei jetzt von Sarah Wagenknecht
an was für Gründen auch immer scheitert
dann ist die Linke auf ziemlich lange
Zeit sehr sehr beschädigt und wird
voraussichtlich auch nicht mehr im
zumindest nicht mehr im Bundestag
vertreten sein spricht nicht viel dafür
dass die Linke selbst wenn wir gar
nichts machen würden wenn wir einfach
nur uns alle ins Privatleben
zurückziehen dass sie dann noch eine
relevante Stimme wäre und das haben wir
halt in die Abwägung auch einbezogen
sangncht wird sich von der Linken
emotional nie völlig lösen können und
sie wird manchmal nachts erwachen und
über politische Freunde nachdenken und
nicht sicher sein ob ihr ung richtig war
im Januar wird die Sara
wagenknechtpartei offiziell gegründet
Oppositionspolitik im Bundestag kann sie
jetzt schon machen sie hat ja bereits
ein Mandat und das wird sie behalten